What was I saying? I don't know. I don't give a, man. What was I saying?
Even I was talking about.
Yeah. But I don't remember what I was talking about after that.
People trying to take it down, whatever. I dunno.
People was trying to take it down. It's actually weird. The that, uh,
you know, what's weird about, um, the thing about,
uh, uh, uh, you know, what, like, okay,
like take the guy who got the SNL and then he said the slurs,
the Asian slurs or whatever, what's weird, you know,
it's weird. And obviously, like, I don't say that.
I don't use those words because you know, it just seems to me,
I don't want to say, well, it's kind of ha hacky. I mean, it's not funny.
So it's weird to say it's hacky, but like, it's just like,
I don't know. It's not thoughtful, I guess maybe, but
the weirdest part about it to me is someone will get, you know, whatever,
whether it be SNL or whatever the it is.
And then immediately the next day there'll be like, well,
this is what they said nine years ago or, or even a year ago.
And this is racist. And
my point is when somebody gets SNL or, or whatever, it is a a Marvel thing,
whatever it is, you know, it happened James Gunn,
I guess he already had the job, but, um,
what's the deal with, well,
we gotta find out how to take them down.
It doesn't even enter my thought process of, okay,
let's find out, let's find it.
Let's find out what the let's find out what he did to him up. Like,
I wouldn't even know, like, I wouldn't even know this guy who did SNL.
I don't know who he is, but so say he gets SNL. I don't know.
He even has a podcast. So who's, you know,
he wasn't famous.
So somebody is actively looking up to go find what this guy did to,
to bury him. I guess. I don't know. I want to know what that is.
What that feeling is that you, that.
I, that, that blows my mind that like, okay, well, okay, so he got this,
I'm going to go look and I'm not excusing what he did, what he said, you know,
it was a racist thing that he said, and that's not cool. And, and I, you know,
it's, but it's just weird that people will be like, okay, well,
what'd he say then? Like I saw one tweet that was like,
we spent all day listening to this, this guy's podcast.
And this wasn't the only thing that we found. Why, why are you,
why are you spending all day to listening?
Something that you don't like,
it's weird as. It's weird as.
It's so weird.
I think people have like this sort of like
weird like, well,
people get it guys get with everyone's is taxi driver character in their mind,
you know, where they're just like the full of scum,
heads, pieces of.
And we're going to take them down.
[Inaudible].
The eerie as music. This city is full of scum.
conce. What is he
looking at? Everyone's feels like they're looking in the, what do you call it?
Rear view mirror. And really we're going to find out his Twitter.
Yay.
We're going to find out what he said 40 years ago.
We're going to find out what he said last year about Asians because they cast
the Asians and then we got to find out what the white guy said. [inaudible]
uh, I think he, I think they do that.
The filth, the hook is the contact.
I think he says continent and Whoa.
He says some there's one thing that's like not acceptable now where it's just
like Robert de Niro is talking about. He's like the, the, the PO the DAS.
Hall's the, the wet dugout cons.
[inaudible] What let's look it up. The Niro,
dude, you know,
has the tide now has the tide. Now dude is the.
Um,
you best believe if I ever got to be as big or as respected as an actor,
as de Niro, I would do all those movies he's doing now. Those movies.
I don't give a. What, what is it called? Taxi driver. Driver monologue.
Monologue. It'll call you talking to me. Things are going to come up of course,
but I'm talking about the, the beginning of voiceover,
probably this was this.
Um, they got for the rain here. It is washes out all over.
[Inaudible].
Seventies, having the long.
Walking down the street, this music
I'm working long hours now, six in the afternoon and six in the morning,
sometimes even eight in the morning, six days a week,
sometimes seven days a week. It's a long muscle, but it keeps me really busy.
I can take in three, three 50 a week,
sometimes even more when I do it off the meter.
[inaudible] really fast. And Mark
[inaudible]
fairies core skunk gone too far. Oh yeah.
Animals come out at night. Okay. Not bad. All the animals. Of course. Buggers,
Queens fairies dope,
junkies up deeper sick Vino, deeper issues.
Some there are real round coming, wash. All this come off the streets.
Is, you know, um,
I guess he doesn't say Kuntz, so I have something going on in my head,
but I'm all good thought. He said.
Well canceled me, I guess. Um, yeah. So, uh, anyway,
that's a weird thing. It is weird. It is weird to me.
Like I like, like I understand, like if you're like doing like,
like what he did was not okay. The, the guy say to say that the racial,
you know, but like that Caroline Calloway thing, did you see this?
Did you guys see the Caroline Calloway thing like this girl?
Do you know what Carolyn, Carolyn Callaway is this girl who,
uh,
like got a bunch of followers in Instagram and pretended her life was one way
and it wasn't.
And she used somebody that was like a girl that was some girl that would like
help her write Instagram, captions and build a brand for her.
And it wasn't really her. And then she started like selling tickets to a, um,
uh, selling tickets to a, uh, an event that was like, uh, uh,
I guess, uh, I don't even know what it was like a meet and greet kind of thing.
That was like a workshop that was like,
you you're going to learn how to be the true you and this and that.
And everyone was like, this is a scam. And it's like, yeah, no. It's a scam.
And she, and then she sold tickets for $165.
And then didn't book the venue and then was like,
we're going to have them all over the country and then canceled them.
And it was like, actually my soul is telling me to have them in New York.
So can everybody just fly to New York? And everyone was like, Oh man,
we already paid for the tickets. And you said you were coming to Chicago.
Of course, what Caroline Calloway is doing is wrong.
But also she's weeding out all the people that are first to go,
okay, if you're buying
$165 tickets to find out who you truly are, guess what he had. Nobody.
Guess what? You are basically a rug.
Guess what you are basically, this watch are.
Oh yeah. Most come out at night.
[inaudible] so British made it up core skunk, skunk.
Uh, is so like crass.
The fact that he wrote that he says skunk pluses, eh, how much did the Niro is?
Like, I'm going to add Scott in front skunk in front of. And of course he, like,
I don't know. I don't know if you need it. And he's like, okay, I won't do it.
And they did it anyway. And then he,
and then he did it one time and he said not doing it again afterwards.
That's what you're using. Um, so,
uh, what was I saying also why what's wrong with fairies? Fairies are beautiful.
They fly around and have wings. I think he means gay, so, so bad, so bad.
So not. So it wouldn't be that way now. Uh, what was I talking about? The,
Oh yeah. Carolyn killer. So yeah, so she,
she sold these tickets and then didn't book the venues and then was like,
trying to be like, this is a four-hour workshop, trying to found out,
find out who you truly are. And like, and like,
like I understand what she's doing is wrong. And,
and she's a piece of flying dog course.
But then there are people like that are like, I have to expose her that, that,
that is a weird notion to me because
Like the writer, it was like,
I wanted to write about my toxic relationship with, um, Caroline Calloway.
And here it is, and now everybody's bashing Caroline Calloway.
And of course she deserves it, but also.
She's.
A moron. Why don't we just let her be like, don't pay attention. I don't know.
That's just how I feel about it. This whole, you did this.
So you're a horse Kong, bugger. You know,
we're going to wash you out from the,
we got to watch the rain the one day a real ran. I come out and wash these.
It's weird. I,
everybody thinks that their taxi driver is the thing behind a keyboard,
your taxi driver behind a keyboard.
And everybody is the real thing is,
is that nobody, I feel like 99% of people, even more,
they don't give a. Like, that's the real thing they just want to get.
They just want to comment.
Like I was looking at some of the Carolyn Calloway's comments and people were
just like, you're fake you. you. And, and,
but they don't even really give a. You know,
they're not going to do anything besides that.
And then people like, uh.
Or talking about, uh, Oh, you know,
She she'll she'll write like, well, I, you know, she wrote something about how,
Oh, I wanted to, I wanted to talk about this article and this is my life now.
And I'm going to, she did a post the other day where she was like, I'm going to,
I'm going to do Coke. Cause anybody you have Coke. And it's like, Hey,
some stuff is private. If you're going to do Coke,
do Coke. But also don't post on Instagram by high, going to Coke.
Okay.
At so weird.